last story of the day is actually my
favorite story of the day so during a
Christmas Mass instead of printing Hail
Marys they actually printed a church
actually printed the lyrics to Tupac's
Hail Mary pulled up on the screen you
got to see this to believe it so this is
actually in the insert and they they
didn't see anything wrong with it when
they started off with Makaveli in this
bleep the killuminati I'm like you know
at some point you have to think this may
not be right the course come with me
Hail Mary run quick seed you know
there's something should tell you once
you got to the line of what's is what's
the most open line I'm not a killer but
don't push me
revenge is the sweetest joy next to
getting you know once you get to that
something that got to tell you that
you're printing the wrong thing in a
church bulletin yeah I'd have to say the
chorus isn't is it going to draw any
eyes to it I think a lot of people make
glance over the chorus oh yeah take a
look at those verses that's clearly not
the Hail Mary they were going for us I
mean like this is this is the gift I
think this was better than Trump over
the weekend like this was a this was a
Christmas miracle for this to happen and
to be printed and then get national
international coverage because Tupac has
made his mark on 2016 Tupac has waited
in on the war on Christmas like this is
this is by all things sacrilegious and I
love it I mean in terms of Tupac songs
though I could have gotten along a lot
worse if what if they printed out like
hit him up talk like that and that's the
one that this is really like the first
the first two words in some of the Tupac
songs are so yeah it could have been a
lot worse
so Hail Mary is the least of the
problems I think and how could this have
possibly happened I mean someone working
at the church decided that they were
going to pull up the lyrics online I
accidentally just chose the ones by the
wrong artist like this is a good
question like so if you google he'll
marry like I don't even you have to have
one you have to have no grounding in
Catholicism which I don't I don't know
anything about Catholicism but I also
like you know do have some common sense
to know that I shouldn't pull it the
very first thing that says Hail Mary
without actually reading through it and
comparing I don't know maybe one of the
altar boys was just trolling everyone
then succeeded and you know what that
could be the case if this was a troll
job this guy wins troll of 2016 he
deserves an award and a round of
applause because this was immaculate you
know as they macula as the conception
you know the dunes all right folks
that's all I've got for today